yo i hear sylvester stallone's gonna be
in mortal kombat 11 yeah gonna fight
reptile
he's the toilet
okay we're gonna watch the mortal kombat
11 ultimate
combat pack 2 and reveal trailer ps4
ps5 let's watch this
oh no
and boone you caved in buddy
oh
[Music]
there's my boy
[Music]
dude stallone came back to play him for
real i love that
item that's great
love it
[Music]
i'm i have so many feelings
so sexy so sexy got molina rayne and
rambo in here
dude plus now you can have him fight the
terminator and have your own experience
people have been like begging at boone
to bring molina back into uh the mortal
kombat games the fans should be
satisfied but sylvester stallone
actually voicing him that's great you
know like they couldn't get arnold to
voice the t-800
because he's busy he's busy you know
calling out trump
doing terminator stuff he's a full-time
job there's content every day yeah he's
way too busy but stallone he's friends
with trump so he has time
if you're gonna go with rocky or rambo a
rambo makes a lot more sense you know
you can get the
assault rifles you can get the hunting
knife you can set traps
i guess well yeah i was like is that
some kind of move you can pull or is
that just like a cool
aspect of the trailer that's maybe
alluding to yeah
finishing move or something like that
and i i mean i appreciate that they
didn't just give it all away
because it got me really excited to see
the kind of things you can do with him
as far as like choosing a stallone
character i feel like rambo is the one
i would feel the most okay with joining
a fighting game like this because if he
were to die
terribly i'm gonna feel really bad if
that's rocky
gonna feel morally reprehensible myself
i'm just very excited that stallone's
actually doing the voice work for it
because a lot of the time you know they
get these
famous characters to be in here they get
a voice actor to
do a voice that sounds like the famous
person to voice that you know
and then here to actually have stallone
coming back here i hope at every
fatality he just goes into his monologue
from the end of first blood where he's
bawling his eyes out
that's it yeah that should be every
fatality and your opponent's head and
heart just
explodes from the drawing i mean you got
to do the one and rambo before
where he puts the fingers in the neck or
it like gets in the tank
and the most bru the most mortal combat
kills are
in that one so ape rambo four as much as
you can and
every level a real war-torn country yeah
molina i'm very excited about i mean
she's been in this franchise since
i think mortal kombat 2 is how long
she's been around i have them all should
show back up before you know you're
going to get
every single og player and you're there
too
they're doing it all they're doing such
a great job with the dlcs of having
nostalgia based characters and then
having
like movie characters come into the fold
as well they they keep knocking it out
of the park
that's how you keep it alive after 11
installments of
a fighting game yeah you know can't wait
for the gameplay trailer dude they gotta
have them versus arnold they gotta do
that
they know they have to what do you guys
think about stallone being in here as
rambo leave your thoughts down below
last but not least
i'd like to shout out my friend tyler
hague tyler if there's anyone at our
patreon page that resembles the most
of sylvester stallone's filmography it's
you you overcome hurdles
like rocky when all odds are against you
you keep flying
in to other people's countries and
committing acts
of terror but you're viewed as an
american patriot you know you're a
head of an elite squad of other people
with your exact
skills you have you just resemble so
much of stallone
in every way and more importantly you
sound like him
you're staying alive man that's a deep
[Music]
cut